[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
reaction pours in from across the
country to derek chauvin's guilty
verdict
what it means for george floyd's family
friends and his legacy i'm not just
fighting for george anymore
i'm fighting for everybody around this
world yeah
the former police officer transferred to
state prison
what was that writing scene on his hand
and when to expect his sentencing
hearing
eight weeks from now we will have
sentencing plus
the department of justice launching a
new federal civil rights investigation
into the minneapolis police department i
strongly believe that good officers
do not want to work in systems that
allow bad practices
law and crime daily covering court cases
from
coast to coast
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm brian ross in our studios in new
york along with co-host terry austin
and brian buckmeyer on assignment in
minneapolis for the trial
of derek chauvin where the verdict was
guilty
guilty guilty and brian was there for it
all brian
brian ross the verdict in the trial of
derek chovin was met with cheers
throughout the streets just outside of
the courthouse
now following those cheers the next two
or three hours
we heard speeches from different
religious and civil rights leaders
talking about this was a moment of
accountability
they said that justice was served but
justice was more of an ongoing process
and that there was more work that needed
to be done we also heard from minnesota
attorney general
and president joe biden commenting on
the verdict
and as you looked around the area you
saw that where there once was
just a number of people having boards
plywood boards
up on their storefronts some people
began to take those down and we saw that
occur
throughout the night one of the other
things that we saw were also
that the family of george floyd
commented on what they had seen
one of george floyd's brothers had this
to say after the verdict
you have the cameras all around the
world
to see and show what happened to my
brother
it was a motion picture the world seeing
his life being extinguished
and i could do nothing but watch
especially in that courtroom
over and over and over again as my
brother was murdered
times they're getting harder every day
10 miles away from here mr wright
dante right that's right yeah he should
still be here
we ought to always understand that
we have to march we will have to do this
for life we have to protest
because it seems like this is a
never-ending cycle
yeah brian the jury was out for just
under 10 hours with 38 witnesses and all
those videos to review
were you surprised they were able to
reach a verdict in that time
i was i thought that just the breadth of
the evidence in this case
as well as the complexity of some of the
jury instructions i always tell people
i went to law school for three years i
practice now for seven years i
understand
how to read a jury verdict and even i
have difficulty in understanding
other states definitions of terms or how
they use
jury instructions and so to have someone
or
12 someone's have to sit there and learn
the language
learn the evidence master it and come up
with a verdict especially a verdict that
is so powerful
for the county and the country i thought
we might have taken a little bit more
time
but i'm not surprised based on the
strength of the prosecution's case
all right thanks brian and now the
department of justice civil rights
division
is launching a new investigation into
the practices of the minneapolis police
department
this is separate from the already
ongoing federal criminal investigation
into george floyd's death
the investigation i am announcing today
will assess whether the minneapolis
police department
engages in a pattern or practice of
using excessive force
including during protests the
investigation will also assess whether
the mpd engages in discriminatory
conduct
and whether it's treatment of those with
behavioral health disabilities
is unlawful it will include a
comprehensive review
of the minneapolis police department's
policies
training supervision and use of force
investigations
it will assess the effectiveness of the
mpd's current
systems of accountability and whether
other mechanisms are needed
to ensure constitutional and lawful
policing
terry austin this is a civil not a
criminal investigation
so what are the options the department
of justice has in this case
so we're going to see this is going to
be a very broad
investigation of the entire minneapolis
police department and what they are
going to be looking at
is all of their practices and patterns
of practices
using excessive force discrimination
they're going to look at stops they're
going to look at
seizures they're going to look at
protests they said they're going to look
at responses to calls with people who
might have
mental disabilities so it's going to be
comprehensive
and i think that not only are they going
to look at these practices but they're
going to as you heard
garland say right there they're going to
look at every single
training and police policy so it's going
to be
widespread and i think other departments
across the country are going to have to
consider
whether they might be next and brian
previous
similar investigations of other police
departments have had a mixed record of
success
what do you think might be different
this time or is it just mostly public
relations
i think it's a little bit of both
actually i think that we saw a case
where the prosecution made it a point to
say we're only going after
this officer and not the others however
we often use the term
uh it's just a few bad apples and i
always hate it because the actual phrase
is
a few bad apples ruin the barrel or the
bin because apples have the ability
to spoil other apples close to them so i
think this investigation
sees that they plucked out one bad apple
being derek shovin
and now they're exploring the rest of
the barrel to see if the other
apples in that barrel have also gone
rotten of course we have three other
officers who are going to be put on
trial
in august and so i think this is the
appropriate stance but of course you
have to balance that to make sure you
don't prejudice
those other upcoming state criminal
cases much more to come certainly about
what president biden called yesterday
systemic racism
still ahead on law and crime daily
witnesses who testified in the derrick
chauvin trial are speaking out
what they have to say about derek
chovin's conviction
but first the writing was on his hand
what was that on derek shelvin's hand
seen as he was cuffed and taken away by
court bayless
we'll break it all down for you coming
up
[Music]
the judge revoked derek children's bail
and he was immediately taken into
custody following the riddling of the
guilty verdicts
long crimes anjanet levy is here to tell
us what life behind bars will look like
for the former officer anjanette
brian typically a defendant is taken
directly to the county jail
after a conviction but not this time
derek chovin was taken straight to
a prison here in minnesota likely for
his own protection
bail is revoked bond is discharged and
the defendant is remanded to the custody
of the hennepin county sheriff
derrick chauvin placed his hands behind
his back and hennepin county sheriff's
deputies handcuffed him
and walked him out of the courtroom if
you looked closely
you could see writing on one of
chauvin's palms
he was taken to oak park heights which
is a prison with an
administrative control unit photos from
the department of corrections website
show what it looks like inside chauvin
is in segregation
away from other inmates for his own
safety and the prison claims it operates
at the highest level of security
a police officer is not seen in a very
good light in a prison setting
and i think a lot of them they they want
to be able to make a name for themselves
have an opportunity to brush up against
him in a hallway in a chow hall
and have an opportunity to get their
hands on them in chauvin's unit
inmates are checked every 30 minutes and
allowed to have books and toiletries
they also undergo mental health exams if
they will be there for more than 30 days
eight weeks from now we will have
sentencing chauvin's lawyer declined a
request for an interview but issued a
statement
mr chauvin's case including sentencing
in approximately eight weeks is still
ongoing
as such i will not be making a statement
at this time
derek chovin was booked into that prison
short
early tuesday evening it's not clear
whether or not he will stay
in that particular prison past
sentencing but it's likely his attorney
will request some type of protective
custody for him while he serves his time
brian and andrea do we know what was
written on derek chauvin's hands in ink
there
well we've been trying to get an answer
to that all day on our own
and i reached out to his law firm and
they didn't have any comment
on that but tmz is reporting that
according to eric nelson
derek chovin had written his phone
number eric nelson's phone number on his
palm because
anything he had with him when he would
take take it to prison would be
confiscated
for from him so obviously he wanted to
be able to reach his lawyer and have
that phone number handy
okay and terry austin what was your
reaction to seeing this 19-year police
veteran taken away in handcuffs
you know i think my reaction was a
little different from when i heard the
verdict i think when
everyone heard the verdict they were
jubilant and it was a
sigh of relief but it is difficult
watching someone being taken off
in handcuffs i have to say though i
think
the jury made the right decision and
they determined
that he should go off to jail that what
he did
was outrageous and that it should be
something he should be held accountable
for and that means
even as a police officer he needs to
serve
his time so it was the right decision it
may be hard to watch
but it definitely is the step in the
right direction
that was the verdict it was murder so
coming up on long crime daily
derek shelvin will be sentenced in two
months and prosecutors are vowing to go
for
more than the maximum sentence we'll
tell you why
plus george floyd's former girlfriend
courtney ross is speaking out about
derrick shovin's conviction
you'll hear what she has to say on the
other side of this break
stay tuned
prosecutors in the derrick showman trial
called the bystanders
a bouquet of humanity many of those who
testified are now speaking out
darnell fraser was just 17 years old
when she recorded the video of george
floyd's death that was seen
around the world on the stand fraser
said
she had stayed up late at night
apologizing to floyd that she didn't do
more
but knew chauvin was ultimately at fault
after the verdict fraser posted this
on facebook i just cried so hard
george floyd we did it justice has been
served
and george floyd's girlfriend courtney
ross who testified about
their struggle with opioid addiction
spoke to the crowd outside the
courthouse
about he how he would have felt about
the verdict
though we are so diverse we are also so
separated
minneapolis is one of the most diverse
cities yet
we are segregated across the city in
little pockets
i know it would be his dream to have
this
event bring us together he has
never been about divisiveness he has
always been about inclusiveness i will
say over and over again
floyd would not forget
those who were forgotten
terry the bystanders were so important
in this case their testimony their
videos what would this mean to the
public at large will encourage others to
get involved and be
citizens looking for police going over
the line do you think
you know let's hope so because what
these bystanders did was pivotal in this
case
we saw darnell fraser's video and it
really
changed the face of that trial i believe
that the jurors at the end of the day
relied on that video and relied on her
testimony and the testimony of
others so i hope that it makes other
bystanders feel as though they can get
involved
on the flip side of that though brian
there's no question that police will be
under more scrutiny
and each case does have to be viewed
separately
we've seen cases like dante wright and
adam
toledo in chicago and just yesterday the
shooting of the 14 year old
mianka bryant in columbus ohio and
those cases are different but let's just
hope that in those cases and in
all the other cases where we have this
sort of police activity
that bystanders will get involved they
will be interested they will come to
court and they will testify
and brian buckmeyer for the bystanders
in this case it's not really over for
them is it aren't they likely to be
called to testify in the trial of the
three other officers who were there on
the scene when they go to trial this
august
yeah it's definitely likely and i think
based on their performance
the way they were received by many in
the jury they'll be definitely called as
star witnesses
i think you're going to see even sharper
testimony
don't forget that many of them were
cross-examined by eric nelson
and he made an appointed fact to mr
williams
especially to say that he was angry he
responded by saying he was in his body
uh miss hansen also her testimony was
strong her cross-examination
was very pointed as well to try to get
her to be flustered in any way shape or
form i think they both did
an amazing job in terms of
cross-examination i would expect
that they would come back for the next
trial and be even stronger
is definitely something i know that
three defendants in minnesota are
thinking about
and weighing out their options as they
are expected to go on trial
in august without a doubt so when we
come back could derek sheldon be facing
more time than the maximum sentence
allowed
everything you need to know about how
much time he'll spend in prison
that's next
[Music]
derek shelvin is set to be sentenced in
eight weeks sometime in june and could
go to prison for decades
if prosecutors get their way law and
crimes anjanet levy is here to explain
how prosecutors say they're seeking to
get a sentence longer than
under the guidelines anjanet
yeah that's right brian and you may have
noticed that during the trial the
prosecution
called several children to testify about
very similar facts and that was by
design
because the testimony of the children
could help determine derek chovin's
sentence
first of all would you tell us how old
you are
nine at that time memorial day last year
how old were you then
17. one by one children took the stand
to testify about what they saw the night
george floyd died
tell us what happened after you saw the
ambulance come
he asked the mlms had to push him off of
him did you notice anything about what
mr chauvin was doing
with his body yes at one point i saw him
put more and more weight onto him
prosecutors filed a notice last year to
seek an
upward sentencing departure meaning
they'll ask for a longer sentence than
allowed by law
the fact that the crime happened in
front of children is one of the reasons
why a longer sentence may be sought
the judge can depart downward but he
cannot depart
upward unless a jury makes certain
findings but in this case attorney eric
nelson asked chauvin
after closing arguments whether he would
waive his blakely rights and have judge
cahill
not the jury decide whether the state
proved aggravating factors existed
i'm willing to waive it and have judge
cagle to sign those issues
former hennepin county public defender
mary moriarty says judge cahill could
increase the prison sentence
but it's not a given of course if the
judge gives
an upward departure that would be a
ground for appeal
and the state wants to make sure they
have a really good record
establishing each basis for a departure
the state of minnesota sentences people
based on guidelines meaning there's a
range of sentences that could be given
unlike other states that have set
sentences for
certain crimes there's a scoring system
that's used based on a defendant's
criminal record that helps in
determining the number of years
he or she should receive in both the
state and the defense
will be submitting briefs to judge
cahill arguing for both a longer
and a shorter sentence brian thanks
angeannette anjanette levy in
minneapolis
and judge peter cahill explained to
derek shovin after the verdict
how the next few weeks will work as the
attorneys prepare their briefs for
sentencing
with the guilty verdicts returned we're
going to have
blakely you may file a
written argument as to blakely factors
within one week
the court will issue findings on the
blakely factors the factual findings
one week after that we'll order psi
immediately
returnable in four weeks and we will
also have a briefing on after you get
the psi
six weeks from now and then eight weeks
from now we will have
sentencing we'll get you the exact dates
uh
in a scheduling order is there a motion
on behalf of the state
they would move to have the court revoke
the defendant's bail and remand him into
custody
pending bail is revoked bond is
discharged and the defendant is remanded
to the custody of the hennepin county
sheriff
and brian buckmeyer however much time
derek shovin spends in prison behind
bars
time for a police officer in prison is
doubly hard isn't it
it definitely is they're going to have
to put him in protective custody
i cannot see him being in general
population is just going to be difficult
based on where he is
and i think that's something that derek
chovan knew and understood
and i think that's why if you recall he
wanted to do the 10 years if he could
plead guilty to the murder in the third
degree or a lesser charge
but only if it was done in federal
prison i think it's not only a danger
for him to be in prison but also
to be in danger in a prison uh in a
state or a county
where he may have put a lot of people in
that prison so they're definitely make
sure to protect him at all times when
he's there
and terry austin in addition to the
aggravating factors that anjanet talked
about with the presence of the miners
are there other aggravating factors that
the judge will take into consideration
and how does he decide you know it's
interesting he's going to look at the
facts of this case and yes there
are other aggravating factors where we
might see this sentence go
up one of them is the fact that the
individual
was handcuffed and he was particularly
vulnerable and we know for a fact
that he was in the prone position and
that he was handcuffed
and that people were on his back and on
his neck so the judge will look at that
and they're going to look at also
whether or not there was cruelty
involved and whether chovin actually
abused
his authority so the judge is going to
consider
all of that in addition to the fact that
this all occurred in front of
children and we heard that those
children obviously came to testify so
the judge is looking at
a number of factors which is going to
help him make his determination as to
the facts
and then he will apply the law to those
facts
and terry shoven did not testify during
the trial can he testify during the
sentencing phase
i don't think he will hear i think for
the very reasons that he said
it's up to the judge to determine
whether or not these
aggravating factors will come into play
it seems as though
he has resigned himself to the fact that
whatever has gone on in trial is going
to be the determining factors
so i think we're going to just see the
judge make a decision here
and in eight weeks we're going to have a
determination
as to how many years exactly tobin will
be spending in jail
and once again all eyes will be on the
hennepin county courthouse
in june when the sentencing is announced
all right brian and terry thank you so
much
and thanks all of you for joining us
here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice
in america
[Music]
you